The phone lines are on fire right now.
You should see the phone bill I'm about to
get.
Let's go back to the phone lines at six one
seven eight three zero.
Forty seven fifty.
Let's check in with Don Tell from Florida.
Last time when Don Teller called in, we went
to Don Telle and the line was dead.
But I'm glad to see that.
Don, tell us back what's going on with you.
Hey, so I wanted to talk about kind of the
direction of the Letwin movement, and you're
so lucky.
So, yeah, a lot of people on the left, myself
included, made the calculation a while ago
that the best strategy to get social Democratic
policies implemented would be by taking over
the Democratic Party.
I would suggest this democratic revolution.
But now that we're a pandemic, unprecedented
economic crisis, we're literally in a political
reality that no one could have ever expected
or anticipated.
So any elected progressives, they failed miserably.
They've got no major policy wins.
And by their own admission, they don't even
plan on getting important policy like Medicare
for all UPI debt and rank cancelation for
at least four years, maybe even longer than
that.
So how effective do you think the progressive
take over the Democratic Party has been?
And do you think that the majority of the
country that was already living on the brink
before the all of this happened?
Do you think that they can go into the four
years without that careful or you'll be guy
over the equation?
So, I mean, there's a lot of questions in
there, Don, tell.
The first thing is, did did you say something
about canceling everyone's rent for four years?
Everybody lives rent free for four years?
Or are these government subsidized?
Okay, yeah, I, I've not even heard that proposed.
Who proposed that?
Yeah, that's the thing nobody proposed me
to.
Oh, you want it?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You want rent canceled for four years.
They're by all estimates, at least 20 million
or 20 million people are expected to be evicted
by October.
Yes.
So this this is as a result of the pandemic
and economic crisis.
And neither of them are going anywhere anytime
soon.
Right.
So it doesn't make sense to cancel, read or
at least have government subsidized rent for
the duration of the crisis.
OK, yeah, I just I guess I just I think four
years is a nonstarter.
And I don't I don't think the crisis is going
to last for years, I hope.
I have like four years.
I think that the progressive beer plan isn't
to get any Medicare rolling, UPI or anything
like that for at least or you actually have
some sort of super majority idea.
Oh, I misunderstood you, Don.
Tell them sorry, you weren't proposing canceling
it for four years.
You were saying there's not going to be any
proposal to do it for the four years that
Joe Biden would be president.
I think I now I understand.
You're right.
Yes.
OK.
So listen, progressive takeover.
The progressive takeover of the Democratic
Party.
I think that a lot of this is about managing
expectations.
And I know you and I don tell have had our
differences over the time that you've been
calling in, but this may be one of them.
My perspective is that the progressive takeover
you would like to see may not be in line with
what most Democratic voters actually want.
And what I would point to is that Biden really
won the primary not by a little, but really
by quite a bit.
I mean, he was up two million votes at the
point at which Bernie kind of started to white
flag.
And so I'm coming at it from a different approach,
which I'm obviously glad to hear how you disagree
with it.
But my approach is a Joe Biden said that he
would use the Green New Deal as a framework
for his climate plan.
And he he has to a great degree.
And in fact, there were Bernie supporters
who are mad that he copied stuff from Bernie
on climate.
It's like, that's good.
I want him copying stuff from Bernie on climate
in terms of his tax plan.
It's a far more progressive tax plan than
what Barack Obama wanted.
And if it becomes a reality, it would be a
significant incremental step.
I mean, in limiting eliminating stepped up
basis and capital gains, you know, a lot of
different things.
So we might have different expectations.
And that's OK.
I want to work together with with folks with
your perspective, Don.
Tell.
But I think that when we talk about a progressive
takeover, we're probably talking about two
different things.
And as you're defining it, we're not going
to see it under Joe Biden, that's for sure.
Are we going to see the most progressive platform
of any president in history?
If Biden is elected, right?
Not if not plot platforms that have been proposed,
but of an actual officeholder.
That's what Biden would be if he wins.
I know what you're saying about that.
And the first one that you made about the
Democratic Party, the voters in the Democratic
Party aren't as myself or as I think they
are.
I strongly disagree with that.
If you look at the exit polls from basically
every state, the primary Medicare for all
was in the majority.
And that was even before we had a public health
crisis like a deadly global pandemic.
Yep.
So I think that it's not a matter of the voters.
I think it's just it's not working in the
Democratic Party that may.
No, don't tell.
Can I just push back a little bit about what
you said?
So you if I want to make sure I understand
what you said, you said you see, you believe
that the Democratic Party actually is as left
as you believe it to be.
And as evidence, you said that the exit polls
show showed a majority want Medicare for all.
Did I understand you correctly?
OK.
So the polls I've looked at do show a slight
majority of support for Medicare for all in
the Democratic Party when no information is
given.
But as more information is given about how
it would work, the support goes down to the
low 40s, high 30s.
So I may be looking at different data than
you, but I don't know that that's the proof
you're necessarily looking at.
I'm not sure I agree with that because we've
got a lot of people frame it, but certain
posters, when they ask the question, be asked
in a way, they frame it in a way like, oh,
I want to keep everybody in the country off
their private insurer.
Yeah, but I'm not talking about those polls.
No, I know those polls are those are push
polls and those are not trustworthy.
But there's good data, like, for example,
there's a great PowerPoint from the Kaiser
Family Foundation, which which has nothing
to do with Kaiser Permanente.
It just happens to both be called Kaiser and
they don't do that.
And they show that as people learn more about
what Medicare for all entails, support does
go down to about 38, 39 percent.
OK.
You did.
And I'm one of the blessed because I feel
like I ever have to finish these conversations.
Sure.
Other small YouTube channel.
It's called Unapologetic and Bold.
Twenty six hundred subscribers.
And so I was just wondering if you'd like
to have me on the show to do like an interview
or a segment or something that we could talk
about some of these issues in more detail?
Well, you're on the show right now.
Don't tell.
You're one of our most frequent callers.
You've been on so much.
Yeah, but I feel like it's so pressure to
try to get, like, all the points that I want
to make into half of a six minute set with.
Oh, right.
And a little luck.
But, you know, we think about that when things
calm down a little right now.
And I'm not you know, let's let's explore
that when things calm down a little.
How about that?
I appreciate be controversial and you take
my calls for over a year now.
Yes, sir.
All right, Don, tell.
Don tell from Florida.
There he is.
He speaks for himself.
I don't have to say anything else about it.